This guy remembers his credit card in his
head, his full 20-digit credit card number,
and he won't remember something we talked
about 4 days ago. He's a special specimen. Yep,
that's us. You might be wondering
how we got here. Wait, who are we?
[music]
Oh yeah, so we wanted to mention how our weekly draws they run from
Sunday to Sunday right so every like Sunday at
8:00 p.m. it restarts. We calculate the winner for
the previous week and then we issue the number of
tickets to each user for the next week. Exactly.
Um, we wanted to test that last Sunday. I like
call Luke at 7:55 p.m. Yo, hop on, open up your
your simulator, put a timer, make sure you get the
seconds in there so we know exactly when it hits
8 p.m. Didn't work like Yeah, we we obviously did
not have enough time. Yeah. And unfortunately
the the testing period is gonna have to wait
till next weekend and we'll be more prepared at
that time. Yeah, that's our debugging update.
[music]
Yo Luke, what do you think of these
animations? I was uh going through and I found
a cool sort of like pack. Okay. So, this
one for like That's pretty good. Earning
tickets sort of thing. Or this one for earning
tickets. Okay. This one for like if you're the winner. Oh,
wow. I like that spin. Like this for like when
payout is completed or something. These are free?
I think so. It says free here. Okay. I'll have
to download it. Like I know we have a limit so
it may count towards our limit but uh I think
you can just like create a new account under
a different email. We'll definitely make sure
that we respect all um copyright laws and all
that stuff. Oh Yeah yeah. It's it's copyright it's
good. It's more the platform which have limits but
[music]
All right. So basically we uh I set up Posthog
last night. Um Luke's going to get set up now and
then if you want to just sort of go through what
I did, check for any errors, make sure it's all
all good, use the MCP server. Basically what Posthog is, it's an analytics tracking tool. So, uh,
we'll be able to see, you know, what percentage of
users who download the app then actually use it,
what percent sign up, what percent come back
every week. Uh, we can run some testing to make
sure that any changes we make are having like
a positive effect on the metrics that we're
tracking. So, uh, yeah, really cool team. We were
like two weeks late on their startup discount.
actually. You had to be less than two years
old and we incorporated like two years and 10
days ago. Sent them an email, they said it's fine.
So, uh, we also get some like free credits and I
think we can even ask for merch or something from
them. So, Oh, merch. Yeah. I love merch. See,
we've got the merch right now. Yeah. Yep. Of
course. The only only hoodies we own. Mhm.
[music]
All right. So, exciting update. We saw a couple
months ago that someone pretty high up at Wealthsimple
had joined our waitlist. Finally,
since we sent our first email out and whatnot
to the waitlist members, I decided to reach
out to him on LinkedIn just to connect and say,
"Hey, appreciate you supporting us or at
least that we're on your radar." I don't
know if you want to come see Luke, but he was
doing some research on the concept. Found our
project. Thought it was pretty cool. So,
we're going to have a meeting with him. So,
to get to know about him. I've been watching some
of his podcasts, learning about his stuff and
uh where I worked before. I heard great things
about him. Really excited stuff and excited
to have that first sort of conversation with
Wealthsimple and see where it leads to.
Now, you might be thinking, who is this guy?
That's me, the editor. I came late this day.
I'm also the only one of the three core members
who joined after the founding of the company.
Here's how that happened. Let's tell them how we
met. It's like we're we're breaking the fourth
wall. Oh, we're breaking. We know they're there. Yo camera.
But we're talking together. Hello people. So Luke
and I, we've always been into poker. Like our group
of friends since high school we were playing and
then we discover people at McGill run these games.
Yeah. So we show up and then we meet, you know,
a bunch of awesome people there. Then we meet you. Shoutout Rob,
Phillip, Shamir. Yeah. Yeah. All the OGs.
Yeah. Emile. Obviously I'm like always sort
of pitching the startup and I'm telling everyone
about it and oh guys go go go join the
waitlist. Businessman. Yeah. And then you're like okay yo like I've
been wanting to be part of a startup. I remember
you telling me that. Like I want to build something
and I want to prove myself and we started talking
and seemed like a good fit. I think I lost a lot
of money in that game actually. Like the game that
we were playing I think I was down like 150 bucks
or something. I was really pissed. But then Ben,
like you told me about this like cool like random
side business and I was originally coming in as a
developer to do code. Yeah. I came home to my girlfriend
and then I told her about uh this like random guy
that I met with a fintech company. He wants me
to do some dev work for him. Yeah, I remember
we like met up at the library a couple times,
did some work together. I sort of like talked a
bit about the vision and where I saw it and for
a while I did a little bit of dev work and
then we decided needed more growth. Yeah,
we need more growth content and he put me on
that. And anyway, that's what I have fun with.
I like the camera. Luke and I we're too uh we're
too shy. I mean, hey, we posted our first one. Yeah. That
was my first video where I'm like actually in
it. You know, Luke, too. He's in it. So, uh you
obviously know as the company is more and more
successful, it's going to be a lot easier.
I'm a, I'm a bad cameraman. I missed the action, but the
security guard just came in here and told us to
kick us out. Uh even though we have a 24/7 deal to
stay in this space. So, um Oh. Oh. Oh. Maybe not.
Maybe not. I don't know. They tried to kick us
out. They told us to leave. Nobody's stopping us.
They're stopping us. We're leaving in 30 minutes.
But uh but yeah, the boys are eating. Mine's cold at this point.
some some frozen butter chicken. And yeah,
so we're uh we're out of here for
tonight, but we continue tomorrow.
[music]
Okay. So, here I'm going to purposely not
sign in with Face ID. We're brought back
to the sign in screen. Now, from here,
I'm going to continue with Face ID. Oh,
okay. Well, it's supposed to ask for my
Face ID. So, let's go fix that.
[music]
the workstation. Got he's got Lodavo
running. The app on the phone. Got some stuff
running here. Create personal API. Oh, I should
not be showing our API keys. Oh, I like that zoom in.
[music]
We're approaching our 8:00 p.m. test for the
launch later in like two weeks. Um the the
dev boys are stressing right now, so I'm filming.
Yeah. Hopefully we uh make it. 20 minutes to go.
[music]
Isn't there a chance that neither of you win
the ticket? No. How come? So, we have two we
have two prizes. We have a weekly guaranteed prize
of $100. Right. Which as long as there is a user,
someone will win it. That is calculated by the
ticket with the most matches. And if more tickets
have the same number of matches, let's say me
and Luke, we both have a ticket that has four
out of seven matches. Yeah. Well, then one of us
will be randomly chosen as the winner. Okay. So,
I don't need to get everything right. I just
need to get more right than anybody else. Or
get lucky. Yeah. You just get lucky. And the
$10K is for what? $10K is if you match all seven,
then you win the grand prize. Talk about
him again, please. Bro, why why why would
you talk about Posthog again when we already
filmed that last Friday? I forgot, man. See,
that was This guy remembers his credit card in
his head, his full 20-digit credit card number,
and he won't remember something we talked about 4
days ago. Obviously not. He's a special specimen.
Obviously not. First official test run uh in 8
minutes. Yeah hide all the fancy code. Hide all the
all the. So, what's happening right now is
it's almost 8:00 p.m. and at 8:00 p.m. on Sunday,
we're going to get the seventh number of the draw
and that's when the snapshot of everyone's tickets
bank account is going to be taken so that the
tickets are going to be frozen for the next week.
Noo, you don't have to watch that.
[music]
I'm stressed like Yeah, I'm I'm good to start
testing. Oh, well, we should delete our old users.
Alright. Yeah. See, cuz I'm like I'm logged in.
So, let's Do we have time? Yeah. Yeah. Go time.
Go time. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Moment of
truth. Yeah. Okay. Is the app app we have spent. Let's
go. Gotta be quick. Slow McGill Wi-Fi. I'm setting up
right now. So, I'm trying on the simulator. Oh,
I'm going to put WAITLIST. Oh,
sh** I'm going to get more tickets than you.
Nice beautiful animation screen. First,
create your account. You get the little
introduction here. I already know how to do
this. And then yeah. So link the first account
Link both of them.
This one I'm not going to link a bank account.
I'm just going to enter your code and see if I
got my tickets without linking an account. Okay. Let's try a
weird birthday. Let's get a February 29th. Guys,
what year was was it a leap year? I don't
know. Aren't you like super smart? No,
we're we're good. Like we already created
enough accounts. I'm just I'm doing extra. Wait but Ben.
Okay. So, it released the winning number this week
early. I think it's glitching. Oh, revealing.
What the Yo, can you film this? Just for like dev.
Yeah. Why is it busting around? Yeah it's glitching.
It was doing that on Luke's phone, but yeah, did you get
the reveal? Yeah. And then it's going back and forth,
eh? Okay. So, yeah. I don't know why the screen
is moving like this. Why is it busting around,
brother? Yeah, it's it's having trouble loading
the uh the data from the API. So, it's like it's
alternating between uh new screen I made a uh two days ago. Oh nice.
It shows like your tickets breakdown. Oh,
so we got the winner, eh? Oh sh** wrong
way. So, so here "no winner this week". So,
it properly says that. Huh? Oh, for that
one. Okay. Yeah. What about for the every
everyday winner? So No. No. So, like, so
it's saying last week there were no users,
so there's no winner this week. Okay. Now, we'll
see in the back end, I guess. So, the front end
is not displaying. It should say that we have like
we each got I should have 100 tickets cuz I used
the waitlist promo code. Right. It says zero.
We'll go check the data. See if I actually do
have 100. And it's just reading reading the data wrong. Yeah.
Or if it just didn't register at all. Luke,
you should open your logs. See what it said.
I have no logs. What do you have no logs? You
always have logs. Good. You want to get food? Yeah.
Honestly, not bad. We know what needs to be fixed.
We will investigate deeper, I guess. See like
um if things are small issues or big issues, but
uh hey at least we got to go through the whole- yeah we'll check the database after supper.
Like front end, everything basically worked like
someone was able to download the account the app
create an account link their Plaid account. Yeah.
And view home screen just with bad data. right?
Yeah. The number got revealed early. Oh yeah.
Pretty cool. We're capturing bro's disappointed face.
Huh? I'm not disappointed. No,
Be happy. I'm waiting for my
one-time password. Progress. Progress.
I'm very happy. Good. And now you get to go
eat. We will talk about later if uh I guess
about like investing into the company. Oh,
we'll have to balance how much, you know,
like there's no no one's forced to to put
in, but also like then you can't complain
if you get diluted. Tired, man. Hey, it's only
8:00, man. You got at least four more hours in
you no? Uhh. This guy's like this guy's an
early bird boy. Yeah. Yeah, I need a break.
[music]
Postgame interview. Good call.
Hopefully to get uh beep partnered with us,
but it's secret for now. Why are you so close, bro? Cut cut cut.
[music]